April the 16th, 1918. Jesus comes hidden in our pains. This is a very important message
as well, and answers lots of questions that people ask. What about my pains? And I always
say, before you go for the panda dog, read this. Continue in my usual state, I felt my
poor heart, or pressed in the midst of bitter pains, which is not necessary to give in
detail. Thanks be to God. So in Jesus' said, my daughter, I send pain to souls so that
in the pain they may find me. So the first thing you're hearing is that the pain, whatever
it is, whether it's physical, mental, emotional, or spiritual, is a nudge from the Lord, saying,
do you remember me? Okay. I am as though wrapped within the pain. And if the soul suffers
with patience, with love, she tears the wrapping that covers me, and she finds me. Otherwise,
I remain hidden in the pain, and she will not have the good of finding me, and I will
not have the good of revealing myself. He's in everything, no matter what we experience.
And then he added, I feel an irresistible force to spread myself towards the people. I want
to give you, oh, it's a proverb, 831, the Lord delights to be with the children of men.
I feel an irresistible force to spread myself among the people. And that's also because
God is love. I would like to spread my beauty, that's the first thing, to make them all beautiful.
But the soul, dirtying herself with sin, rejects this divine beauty and covers herself with
ugliness. So he's giving us a very clear picture as to why sin can't have anything to
do with divine anything. So sin is ugliness, and he wants to give us divine beauty.
Number two, I would like to spread my love, but loving what is not mine, they live numb
with cold and my love is rejected. Now loving what is not mine is that you're loving something
material or even worse. I would like to communicate all of myself to man. I would like to overshadow
him completely with my own qualities, but I'm rejected. That's number three.
And in rejecting me, he forms a wall of division between me and him to the point of breaking
any communication between the creature and the creator. Now we're the ones who formed
the wall of division, we being human beings. But in spite of this, I continue to spread
myself. I do not withdraw. This is the unconditional love of the Lord, which is usually given
in the Greek as agape. I do not withdraw in order to find at least someone who would
receive my qualities. And if I find that person, I double my graces for him. I increase them
to 100 fold. I pour all of myself into him to the point of making him important of grace.
In other words, the Lord is so thrilled to find somebody who would let him work within
them that there's no limit to what he will give you. Therefore, he said, remove this
oppression from your heart. Now, the oppression is what we allow to get in on ourselves, the
anxiety, the low moods and all of this kind of stuff. Remove it from your heart, he said.
And pour yourself into me. That's your fusing. And I will pour myself into you. Jesus told
you this, and that's enough. Have no concern about anything, and I will do, and I'll take
care of everything. We find it very difficult in actual practice to let the Lord do everything
for us. We agree theoretically, all right. But we have a great fear of losing control.
That someone else might be in control of our lives. We find that extremely difficult.
That's why he says that the final surrender of the will to him is the greatest thing he
can ask, and he won't ask anything else. So, April 25, 1918, Jesus plays with Louisa.
One of the wrong images that were passed on to us in childhood was that God was somehow
a domineering figure up in the sky who would give you a whack if you were two minutes
late for anything, or if you didn't pull up the scratch and all the rest of it. And the
idea that the Lord might want to play with you would be off the richer scale. And so,
we have not allowed God to show himself the way he wants. So, Louisa said, "I was saying
to my sweet Jesus, my life, how bad I am." Now, the word "bad" is the word she uses
as "cativa," and it really means an awfully little thing. It doesn't mean bad as in sinful,
otherwise she has no relationship with him at all. But even though I am "cativa," and
I like the fact that they keep the word, I know that you love me. Now, the way we would
say it is in spite of my weaknesses, in spite of the fact that I don't really come up to
the mark all that often, you still love me. And the salvific point there is that he loves
us, because then you will be able to come round. I don't know what you say to the Lord
if you are having a bit of a crisis. I just say to him, "Hold on to me until I come round."
So in other words, he is hearing, "I don't want to break." And so, Jesus said, picking
up the word that she used, he said, "Okay, my bad, little one," he said, "You surely
are bad, but you have captivated my will." In other words, you are so bad that you have
captivated my will. Can you see him playing with her? Okay. "Had you captivated my love,
my power, my wisdom?" He said, "You would have captivated part of me. But by captivating
my will, you have captivated the whole substance of my being." Now, somebody is going to ask
you, "What is divine will?" The answer is, "The divine will is the essence of God."
You have captivated the whole substance of my being, which crowns all my qualities and
therefore you have taken the whole of me in one leap. This is why I often speak to you
not only about my will, but of living in my will, because since you have captivated it,
I want you to know all about its qualities and the way of how to live in my volition,
so that you may live common and inseparable life together with me. Now, that word inseparable
is extremely important. That means the human love is lost in the divine. The human will
is lost in the divine. The human life is lost in the divine. The human works are lost in
the divine, inseparable. And up to now, Jesus has only referred, up to now meaning up to
Volume 12, Jesus has only referred to his mother as inseparable. And from here on in
Louisa is also inseparable, and he wants us also to be inseparable with him. That you
would live common and inseparable life together with me, because that's real union. That's
divine merit, and that I may reveal to you the secrets of my will. Could you be more
Kativa than that? He says, "I absolutely love that." And Louisa said, "You're making
fun of me. I want to tell you that I really am Kativa." He said, "Ah, yes, yes, yes."
She wasn't getting the point. He was trying to tell her, "Listen, if you've captured
my will, which is the essence of me, how can you be bad?" He's also saying to her that
God does not look at us the way we look at ourselves. We often look at ourselves the
way other people look at us. In other words, I'm wearing a white jumper, this one little
black spot, and all your friends will say, "What happened to the black spot?" They won't
say, "What a beautiful jumper you're wearing." They look at the thing that's wrong, and
that has sort of got into us. And so we only look at the sins and the faults and the defects,
and we don't look at what the Lord sees. It's the pity. It's when someone falls in love
with you that they begin to say to you that you actually look different than what you
think. And it's the Lord who is love in essence, who looks at us in love and through love and
sees us as we really are. Okay. The white jumper might have one black spot on it, but
99.99% of it is white. So it's a white jumper. Thank you. You see the way looking at something
makes all the difference to how you respond. So here comes Lent, May 7, 1918. The divine
will grind. What is human? Look at the word. There is a text in 1 Samuel 28, 28, which says
that the Lord threshes the wheat, grinds it down to powder, but it doesn't thresh it
forever. When it gets to powder, that's it. You've arrived. But the part of living in
the divine will that we find difficult is that when the Lord sees a bump that needs to be
straightened out, you know what I mean? He sees something that needs to be dealt with because
we have an extraordinary ability to deceive ourselves unless you're different today. And
so you can think that you're completely given to the Lord. He has a very, very simple way
of testing whether you are completely given to him or not. And that is he'll put you into
circumstances in which you're being asked to do something you don't want to do, most dead simple.
And the no comes up. It's wonderful. So the Lord has to go working on this so that we're
able to really surrender. So continue in my usual state. My sweet Jesus told me, my daughter,
if for a few days you don't see me as usual, do not afflict yourself. She does that all the time,
of course. Evils will increase and heaven and earth will bolt strike man. Take note. That means
chastisements will come from heaven and from earth. And I do not want to afflict you by letting
you see so many evil discussions will go mad, you see. And the Jesus said, "Am I Jesus,
the greatest pain for me is your privation." It's death without dying, a pain indescribable
without end. Jesus, what are you saying? "I without you," that's not possible.
Mind Jesus, she said, "Don't say that to me anymore." I tried to give you that the way it was said,
"Don't you go talking like that anymore." She has such an extraordinary relationship with him
that not actually seeing him and talking to him in this way is completely hell for her.
We just have to take it as such because if we have not had the same experience
of meeting the Lord like that, we can't even imagine what it's like.
Okay. So Jesus said, "My daughter do not become alarmed. I did not tell you that I would not
come, but only not often. I told you beforehand so it's not to make you worry. Look at the way
God is reaching down to a little creature, and he's the one who told us he's only in Adam.
Why would he pay so much attention to long-lived Adam? This is incredible. And this is the way
we have to sort of touch the enormity of this revelation that God is pure love. That's why he
would give that amount of attention. I told you beforehand so as not to make you worry.
"My will will compensate for everything because in my will the human will is ground down."
In other words, we've used ourselves in the divine will. We do know that we're not perfect,
but when the divine will says, "Do you mind if I remove this vision?"
We wasn't like it. Even though we know we're not perfect. Because in my will, the human will
remains ground down. And I extract the flower, the fruit, the crafting of my will, and I place it
together with me to live a common life. Only the bit that's been divinized can live in common with him.
And the human, like Bran, remains separated and remains outside. So eventually the Lord
needs us to become totally spiritualized. And you will see this when you get to the
higher volumes that Louisa herself has become totally spiritualized. It's a fascination to watch it.
"Therefore, let the machine of my will grind you thoroughly." I think that's Isaiah 28, 28.
"So that nothing human may remain in you."
So our surrender to him is also giving him permission to do what he needs to do.
That's like saying, "I become a patient in a hospital and I sign a consent form
that I will allow the doctor to do whatever is required to get me out of where I am into where
I should be." But notice nowadays they get you to sign as a consent form.
May the 20th, 1918, everything, but everything is concentrated in the divine will.
"Continue in my usual state, I was saying to my sweet Jesus how I would like to have your desires,
your love, your affections, your heart, etc. So that I would be able to desire and love, etc.
as you do. So then Jesus tells her how to do it. "My daughter," he said, "I don't have desires."
"How could he have desires? That desire means you're lacking something and he lacks nothing."
It's very interesting. "I don't have affections," he said, "but everything is concentrated in my will.
My will is everything to me." One who cannot do something desires,
but I can do anything because he's omnipotent. One who does not have love,
wants love, so desires it. But in my will there is the fullness, the very source, the sound of true love.
And since I am infinite, in one simple act of my will I possess all goods,
which overflowing from my being descend for the good of all.
If I had desires I would be unhappy. I would lack something, but I possess everything.
Therefore I am happy and I make everyone else happy. Infinite means having the power to do
anything. So that's the omnipotence of God. It means possessing everything and making everything
happy. Now notice he is talking about beatitude all the time. The creature who is finite does
not possess everything nor can she embrace everything and that's why she contains desires, anxieties,
affections, etc., which she can use as many steps in order to ascend to her creator. That's John 1.51.
She can use to lap up the divine qualities in herself and be filled so much as to overflow
for the good of others. That's John 7.39. So the next little paragraph we talk about the possession
of God. But if the soul concentrates all of herself, now all means 100%, not 99, 100% of herself
in my will, dissolving herself completely in my volition, then she will not just lap up my
qualities, but in one single gulp she will absorb me into herself. That's the possession of God.
And she will no longer have within herself her own desires and her own affections,
but only the life of my will which dominating her completely. We sang it in charismatic days.
He is Lord. He is Lord. As only at this point, he really is Lord in our lives. Dominating her
completely will make everything disappear. Everything disappear is everything that's human,
that holds her back. I will make my will reappear in everything. Matthew 6.10.
Now that description you got there, I think it's all one sentence, actually shows us the reordering
that has to happen in us in order that God can take over and that the relationship that God had
with Adam before the fall can be restored. So May the 23rd, 1918, the flights of the soul
in the divine will. This morning my sweet Jesus did not come and I spent it amid
sighs anxieties and bitterness, but all immersed in his will. That's Sam 42 verses 1 to 3.
And Sam 63 verses 1 to 8. Sam 42 verses 1 to 3 says, "I have nothing but tears from my bread,
night and day, as they say to me all day long, where is your God?" And Sam 63 says, "Oh God,
you are my God for you, I long, for you my soul is thirsting, even my body is pining for you."
And so on. So those two sounds fit Louisa in her privation points.
As night came she said, "I could take no more and I kept calling him over and over again.
My eyes could not close. I felt restless. I wanted Jesus at any cost."
Now there's a point that we can check for ourselves. How badly do we want Jesus?
It's only when we know how badly we want him, we will know what we would pay as well.
She wanted him so badly that she would have not any cost. So at that point the Lord knows that
somebody actually loves him. So at that point he came and he addresses her as my dove. Now for
that you need to go to the Song of Songs, chapter 2 and verse 14. And chapter 6 verse 9,
where the bride in the Song of Songs is addressed as my dove.
My dove, who can say to you the flights that you take in my will?
The space that you cover and that the air that you swallow. That's a very interesting expression.
It's just the air that you swallow. So I want to give you Sam 55 verses 67.
"No one, no one, not even you," he said, "would be able to understand." Now my book says,
say it. It's really understandable. You wouldn't be able to understand it. "I alone, I alone can
comprehend it. I who measure the fibers, I who number the flights of your thoughts." Now Matthew 10,
30 says that the Lord even counts the hairs of our head, which I would call a waste of time,
but never mind. He said, "I who number the flights of your thoughts and of your heartbeats.
And as you fly, I see the hearts that you touch. Jeremiah 17, 10, the hearts that desperately need
to be touched. But do not stop. Fly to more hearts and knock again and again." Okay.
I just remembered something there. And that's Revelation 320, I think it is. Behold, I stand
at the door and I knock. Do you remember that one? And if you open up to me, I will come in.
And so the Lord tells the soul in the divine will, "Go and knock on people's hearts. Go and knock
on their hearts. They've got to be called." And so the evangelization that we do in the divine
will is all interior. The evangelization that other people do is exterior people. And I've been there
as well. But you go to their countries and you teach them or you heal them or whatever it is.
It's exterior. This is entirely interior. It's on a different level altogether.
So don't stop. Fly to more hearts and knock again and again. And fly over again and on your wings.
On your wings, I will bring my I love you to more hearts. So there's the soul like a little airplane
traveling all over the world to different hearts. And the Lord allows his I love you
to take a ride on that little airplane. I will bring my I love you to more hearts to make me loved.
So you can see here the need for all of us to do multiple acts of reaching out to other souls
and to give the Lord a chance to ride on us. I think that's a beautiful image. It touches me
very much that the Lord would ride on my back with his I love you to some soul I want to reach.
To make me loved, he said. And then in one single flight, he said,
"Come into my heart and take refreshment and then start again your rapid flight."
So come back to me. Have a cup of coffee and fly off again. I enjoy myself with my dove,
actually because this dove, I love the image because it's a word. The dove is actually doing
what the beloved wants. And I call the angels and my little mother. Look at the word little.
There's the nothingness to enjoy themselves with me. But you know, I'm not telling you
everything. He said, "The rest I'll only tell you in heaven." I think that's brilliant. In other
words, no matter what I say, your mind is so limited. You couldn't possibly take the whole
thing. And if you could, you probably die of joy. How many surprising things I will tell you in heaven.
And then he placed his hand on my forehead and he said, "I leave you the shadow of my will,
the breath of my volition." Look at that going asleep. It's never wonderful. The shadow of my will
and the breath of my volition. I knew he'd come to the jealousy. May the 28th, 1918,
the jealousy of the love of Jesus for a Louisa is so great that he takes everything away from her.
Now, one of the things that you're told quite frequently in the first five books of the Bible,
the Torah, the most sacred part of the Bible, is that God is jealous of his people.
And what that means is that he's the husband, the people are the wife. God was the bridegroom,
Israel was the bride. In the church, Jesus is the bridegroom, the church is the bride.
In the individual person, he is the bridegroom, the individual person is the bride.
He wants complete possession as every husband does. He wants complete possession and he wants
that bride completely in him so that they operate entirely as one.
I think that what we look at in our everyday life, like the experience of marriage,
is only a pale, pale picture to point to what the Lord is actually trying to do with us all,
both individually and collectively. Now, to give you just a few references to the jealousy of God,
there's lots of them. I'm only going to give you a few. Exodus 20, verse 5. Exodus 34, verse 14.
So, Exodus 20, verse 5. Exodus 34, verse 14. Deuteronomy 4, verse 24. And Deuteronomy 5, verse 9.
Now, another way of saying jealousy, and you'll be more used to the other way, is that God wants
a non-divided heart. Okay? And the undivided heart is Deuteronomy 6, verses 4 to 10. You have to love
the Lord with all your heart, all your soul, all your mind, and all your being. And that's actually
lodged in human marriage as well, because the spouse, either spouse, won't tolerate the other
spouse, loving somebody else, because the relationship is exclusive. And so, this exclusive relationship,
the Lord has with these people, and He has with each individual soul. And that's why they call
it jealousy, because the Lord will really defend His people. And it's fascinating when you go through
the Old Testament to see what the Lord does to defend His people, and what the Lord will do to
defend His church and the individuals that are in it. So, Louisa said, "Finding myself in my usual
state, I was saying to my beloved Jesus. Jesus loved me. I have more right than others to be loved."
Why would she say that? Because she's given completely to Him. She's entirely at His disposal,
24, 7, 3, 6, 5. Because neither do I love anybody but you. Now, that's something we can check for
ourselves. Is there somebody we love besides the Lord? That means, is there something that I'm
committed to besides Jesus? Like we have people going to church, and they're also going to new
age things. So, they're not loving the Lord exclusively. They don't realize that when they go to
a Tai Chi and what do you call that other thing? The yoga and all the rest of it, that they're
actually loving another God. They don't realize it because they've been caught on this deception.
So, one of the things is very, very clear that what we must clarify is there anything in me
that I'm putting ahead of Him. And that's something we need to check all the time,
because we can put some material thing. We can put a person, an attachment to a person.
We can even put an attachment to an experience and make it different to the Lord.
And you can also put yourself ahead of it. I'm the great teacher who is she worshiping.
Your finger points back at herself. Or I'm the great healer. Now, you wouldn't use the words,
but you see people acting that way, that I'm the important person. I remember giving a retreat at
one stage. I'll try and keep this anonymous, okay? And it was an old man's retreat. Now,
say Paul tells a woman shouldn't tell a man what to do, but never mind. And I said to the group,
are we all in? And they said, well, not quite. So I said, do we have to wait for this one other?
And they said, so I realized this one other was somebody very important and there were double
doors. And next thing the double doors opened in walks, this huge man. And the entire message that
came with them was, I've arrived. You may begin. I said, wow. There's somebody not even on the platform.
He's worshiping himself. I've arrived. And all the others knew that this was going to happen.
So someone who asked me privately was I impressed. I said, yes, but in the wrong way.
I said, the poor lad's not even on the platform. He doesn't know what worship of God is.
He's too busy with his mirror. So we have to be very careful not to put something
ahead of the Lord. And it can be something very small. It doesn't have to be something huge.
So Louisa said, I have more right. And she said that I don't love anybody else but you.
Nor does anyone love me. She said, it's a rather interesting round. And if someone seems to love
me, she said, it's for the good that comes to them. That's rather interesting as well. That,
you know, if you're good at something, people want a slice of the cake. I remember talking to
some Nigerians, I think it was some couple of years ago, asked them how were they doing in Ireland.
And they said, we want to share in the Irish dream. I said, now I've been here all my life.
What's the dream? But if your country is perceived to have something, somebody else wants a slice of
the cake. And if you're good at something like teaching or healing or anything, they want a slice
of the cake. So they might want you, but it's not actually you. It's what you're going to give to them.
So Louisa said, even the ones who seem to be friendly, it's what they're going to get out of me.
So they're not really loving me. She could see it quite clearly. Therefore, she said,
between my love and yours, no other love enters in the middle. There's her completely given to God.
And Jesus said, my daughter, this is nothing other than my strongest love.
It is such that the jealousy of my love for you takes all things away from you. So please
realize that if the Lord takes a person, a thing, an experience away from you, He's loving you. He's
now hating you. He's like the mother who finds the little child playing with the carving knife
in the kitchen. And out of sheer love for the child and everybody else as well, takes the carving
knife out of the hand of the child and puts something safer in. The child might not like it,
but you're actually loving them. And so it's terribly important.
He says, the jealousy of my love for you takes all things away from you. Jesus is saying to her,
I love you so exclusively. I want to take care of you myself. I want to do everything for you.
I don't want anybody else involved. And my jealousy is such that I remain on guard
so that not even a shadow of love, that means on the wrong level of any creature may breathe in you.
At the most, I tolerate that some may love you in me. In other words, they'll have a spiritual
relationship with you, but not outside of me. That means not on the human level. Otherwise,
I'd make them flee. What would an order to make them flee? That means he takes strong action,
gets rid of them. Don't ask me to comment on that. And this also means that neither have you entered
into any other heart nor has any other heart entered into yours. In other words, she has an
undefiled heart, Matthew 5-8, only the pure in heart can see God.
Then around nighttime, Jesus came back with the Queen Mother calling me by name
as if they wanted me to pay attention. How beautiful it was to see Mother and Jesus speaking to each
other. The celestial Mother was saying, now the next paragraph is our blessed lady interseeding
as Louise interseeds for her children. "My son," she said, "What are you doing?
What you want to do is too much." I want to give you John 19-25,
where she was constituted the mother of all humanity. As mother of all the children who were being
chastised, she says, "No, no, it's too much." Like the wife saying to the husband and her,
"Don't go too far with this. Don't go too far." "I have the rights of a mother," she said,
"and I grieve that my children are suffering so much. You want to open heaven for scourges
and you want to destroy your children and the food that will serve to nourish them. In other
words, they cause a famine. You want to destroy them with infectious diseases. You want to inundate
them. Both of them are happening, aren't they? What shall we do?" You say that you love this
daughter of mine. She said, "How much will she suffer if you do this?" So, Blessed Mother is
using Louise as a lever. The tale of Jesus to stop the scourge is, I think that's fascinating.
Look at that just for relationship. I think it's fantastic. You say that you love this
daughter of mine. How much will she suffer if you do this? So, it's not too
in bitter heart. She said, "You won't do it, will you?" That's brilliant.
She pulled him towards me, Louise said. Now, in my book, that's a capital M. Is it capital in yours?
Small M, because it's Louise. And Jesus determined, said, "No, I cannot. He's resisting.
I divert many, divert many evils because of her, but not everything.
My mother, let us allow the whirl of evils to pass." That is over humanity, so that they may
surrender. That is somehow the human race would surrender to the divine will. But the amazing thing
is, we're a century later, have we surrendered? So, even though Jesus is resisting both his mother,
and Louise, I want to give you Sam 14517. Sam 14517, God only ever acts out of love,
because God is love. He's not able to act any other way.
Then they said many other things between themselves, which I could not fully understand.
I remain terrified, but I hope that Jesus will placate himself. So, we're going to stop here for
lunch break now.